hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to sort the court now
this has been updated incredibly because
the previous version that I played was
only a game jam demo this is a full
released version of the game with more
interactions more arrivals of people
that want to join or destroy your
village and possibly an ending I have no
idea I killed the dragon last time but
I'm gonna play it I'm gonna try to only
showcase the new stuff in it so we'll
see you at booming god bah policies I
don't know why I get so burpee I
understand goodbye farewell wait did you
say something about a council that's oh
not you
it usually works out well for me so I'm
gonna do that well eat ten dicks and
call me Sally this is not gonna go well
we're off to a bad start
alrighty then Willis Douglas you tell me
hello yes let's do it well [ __ ] my
10,000 dicks eat a [ __ ] piece of
garbage you [ __ ] okay so this isn't
going very well to begin with but that's
okay my boat Sookie oh yeah you can I
know I know you're good for it I know
you are I know you're gonna be good I
thought you'd come later in the game but
good god uh yeah sure you can build more
houses oh god damn it I'm out of money
on day one and people are sad what
happened to me man I just got done
playing rains the same thing all right
eat him
I need I need money thank you that's a
lot of gold I'm a bad king alright you
better not dick me over this time you
son of a [ __ ] yes finally
alright good it's about damn time should
I go for double or nothing hell yeah I
will I liked far ah death and misery for
everybody
well well hahaha I'm gonna get a game oh
[ __ ] you and your curly but save
people's souls for my goal yeah sure
give me the gold if I'm gonna go down in
a sinking ship we're gonna sink hard
into the very bottom of the ocean well
gloopy buts grandma can I borrow some
cool you know what grandma apparently
this is the video playthrough where I'm
I'm a dick so Chucky grandma who watch
oh my oh no no how could they do that to
Grandma I'm such a dick are you if I
swear I'll cut behind ah well [ __ ]
alright no more gambling no gambling no
gambling I don't recall you but maybe
you came around plants are interesting
sure open up a garden okay that's fine
everybody's happy so we're gonna get
more population anybody and that's gonna
be no alright I'm a little I'm a little
feeling a little spooky it's just a
little spooky
way-hey come on dick oh hey I remember
you from way later in the game LD three
four yeah I'll try to fix you I don't
know if I get home i god that was a lot
of gold us I am become fixed you better
am become helpful to me I come back when
you're all better I remember you had a
log on your legs
names Mulder if you want to know the
truth about everything you're gonna want
to hire me is that reference to x-files
yeah okay all right I'm gonna go
investigate something aren't okay all
right see ya oh I'm never gambling again
I don't need to huzzah this is going
well for me
oh hey LD three four I'm truly sorry
about earlier my circuits were fried but
my thanks for your help thank you thank
you oh thank you you better be of more
help later oh hi
if you see a treasure chest do a back
flip and honestly no like honestly and
truly if I'm asking answering this
question honestly
no I have not well you're not [ __ ] you
you little [ __ ] yeah there's been a
brawl at the tavern should we arrest
those responsible for starting it no
that's an interesting question I haven't
seen this before I'm gonna say brawls
happen who a - oh but they're sure to
cause more trouble if left oh well [ __ ]
I did bad that was not the right call
oh we're growing then that's good so it
is reference to x-files maybe yes no I
don't know I don't know motor at all
okay so now we've made it a good long
way so now we're gonna get into the
thick of it so that was just me getting
to a point where I've made some progress
and maybe seeing a few new things on the
way but now it's gonna start getting
more interesting here and we're gonna
get to the new stuff and find how to
beat this game by the way remember
earlier when I mentioned the Council of
crowns okay yeah there was something
about that I thought you said Council of
crows
but apparently you meant the Council of
crowns what is that heard a rumor that
one of their members has been searching
the land for a new ruler to join them
perhaps they are aware of our product I
am a king I am a kingly King oh you're
so cute oh I don't want you to scare
anybody if I recall something about that
that's bad for my people I don't need
you to scare nobody thank you very much
okay goodbye
I'm back I discovered an alien
conspiracy to cover up large amounts of
gold do you believe in aliens yes I do
cuz one just walked in my front door why
would I not good to know there are other
believers out there okay goodbye I'm
older oh hi
seems your court is without cake I'm a
cake chef yes yes
Oh your cake full your grateful your
cake full I love it
oh hey hey pal you've been a real great
sport I wanted to give you this no
strings attached
really why don't I trust you the devil
entrains was not nearly as nice as you
are thank you oh hi I'm hungry can I eat
some folks you've got plenty of gold we
do have a lot of people and they are
pretty happy all right okay you can eat
some people oh they didn't even lose any
happiness ah cool
Thanks me on there oh you're so good oh
of course I'll pat your belly mr. boots
oh what a little cutie with a little
cutie grab ah yes you open up all the
soup shop you want ah grandma this is a
good day it's a good day that was a good
day I'll of course welcome him in I like
this day we ended up with a plus surplus
population and even Jesse ain't some
people goody goody gumdrops
I accidentally ate some folks out front
can I just pay you back with gold yeah
okay all right okay thanks for
understanding I can't exactly say no to
that I mean what's the point in
disagreeing ah living Letten okay I've
got a friend from wit school looking to
move into town could I get a couple gold
to help her move in you want a lot of
gold all right fine
so long as it acts oh that's not oh
that's fine
oh that's great everyone loves witches
apparently there's a lot more diversity
like to build a granary okay
okay though that's fine I love granaries
I'm a great king hello all right tell a
story a yellow bird meets a green bird
in the sky does yellow bird soar higher
than the green yes if the yellow bird is
the Sun the yellow bird wheels through
the sky she shimmers in the sunlight oh
how lovely high up in the sky the yellow
bird meets a blue bird does yellow bird
stop to sing with it hmm oh the sweet
musical notes of the two new friends
fill the air the singing attracts a
flock of nearby birds of all shapes and
colors the sky is filled with song what
a lovely ending this story don't you
think I'll be liked it I imagine that
Holly right there I will have to come
visit you again sometime kingly person
it's fun to tell stories with you it's
fun when I get gold from it apparently
hey there bud you interested in
something a little bigger maybe some
kind of devil this ritual something
along those lines a lot of souls would
get used up like a lot guarantee you can
afford it though I'm gonna wipe out your
whole city here just lots of folks but
on the other hand you'll get like crazy
amounts of money like I'm talking
serious gold heaps here I got to do it
tonight
moon special right now one chance only
what do you say well you know I'm
feeling this is like the make-or-break
decision for this game
and you're talking heaps of gold I got
lots of people and you don't say you're
gonna wipe out everybody and the moon is
right you did give me 25 go how can I
say no to that yeah all right oh yeah oh
yes ha ha I don't care how many people
just died horribly how many families
were oh my god there's so much gold whoa
ho ho yo yo yo ma ba ba souls for money
Meghan so oh my god
enjoy your riches maybe I'll see you
around again sometimes who knows
thanks Georgie Louie was giving out free
cake much too oh oh that's so nice and
we're growing we're still happy how is
it possible I'm the greatest King ever
my friend from whisker wanted to thank
you so oh you made magical cookies it
doesn't matter how many people died
I still get cookies and cake I love it
Oh
oh no oh oh a dragon's come oh god you
want to eat my people or you'll take my
gold oh god what will uh Novik eat my
people I sacrificed a hundred for them
take it how about [ __ ] take take a pair
of these and then go [ __ ] yourself with
them no I don't give a [ __ ]
thirty anybody [ __ ] you
I'd sacrifice more for that sir I heard
about the dragon yes please craft it yep
do that okay
few hundred fine if it means I get more
gold later I'm okay with that it's a
bunch of goblins yeah killed goblins I
don't like I don't like goblins
don't like him nah hey goblins god damn
it you ate some people again all right
Chester you've is your second strike
though ah Who am I kidding you can eat
as many people as you want okay sure
we're all good here only five oh that's
a light snack Chester you're okay in my
book it's all an accident everybody oh
hi no don't chase it away oh what a
cutie there's a party god there's a
everyone is so damn happy in my kingdom
I love it everyone is so happy I am the
greatest King that ever lived that ever
will live Oh
[Music]
Scully and Mulder I think I made that
connection before my guys are already
pretty happy Georgie and um we did
already make a deal I want to spare any
of my gold hey you know what I never got
anywhere by not trusting this guy imma
trust you
yeah sure make me happy that's me you
basically break a deal that's a lot of
happy doesn't matter if it's good or bad
honestly I just love making deals
damn it Georgie's such a good guy even
though he killed 100 people
what a nice upstanding whatever he is
I've got news for you sire the sir
yay we're 500 strong there's a fest of
all
let's keep working are ya heck yes I'm
working so hard how's it going you me we
really get along I wanted to tell you a
secret I actually humans because of
curse which put on me I'd stop if I
could but you know curses you think you
can help me break the curse I don't want
to keep eating people forever
Oh Chester I knew you had a kind soul
down in there I mean you probably ate it
and then it's staying trapped with
inside but yeah sure all of you break
the curse Oh
keep an eye out for any magical folks
who might be able to break the curse I
know of a goblin slaying hero
My partner Skelly told me you have
information about an alien life-form if
it's true it could change everything
I'll be launching my own debate a man
named Amy oh hello you are new I am your
know of the comfy Kingdom you may not
believe this but I am the Royal
assistant of kingpin himself indeed the
very same I've been noodling around this
Kingdom of yours and I oh wait it's that
over there uh button boy good sir did
you happen to see a blue fellow come
through here just now strange noodley
limbs made of yarn yeah I knew he was
around here somewhere I'm gonna find
that darn Giano he's been running around
claiming to be kingpins royal assistant
which of course he is not in fact it is
I button boy who represents the comfy
Kingdom in the esteemed Council of
crowns have you heard of the Council of
crowns yes I've heard a lot about this
amazing council then you surely you've
thought about joining perhaps we could
work out a bit of a deal that jános been
giving me nothing but trouble if you
could somehow put a stop to his
shenanigans I might be able to get you a
meeting with Pierre the advisor of the
celestial kingdom if anyone would be
able to induct your kingdom into the
council it would be her what do you say
will you help me cap that darn yarn well
I know of a certain grandma that
probably stick a needle in that yarn of
yours I'll help don't worry once yar
nose out of the way I'll set up a
meeting with Pia thank you for your
assistance in this matter
good sir I'm sure we'll meet again soon
thanks bud boy
grandma have I got a job for you oh oh
grandma don't worry about it
grandma everything's gonna be okay it's
alright it's okay
it's the same Mouse from before is he
offering me something yes
mousie he found five coins thank you
mm-hmm it's running wild should we try
to capture it ooh
[Music]
boots is gonna find yarn oh ah that must
be it I'll need provide plenty of tuna
but surely you'll be worth the cost
yeah find yard wow I paint that cat a
lot of gold to find yarn oh but okay
alright okay I'm good for it oh you can
break a curse yes yes oh wait no whoa
whoa whoa wait whoa wait you're gonna
curse him
wait did did that say that you were
going to curse him because is that this
gonna make it more ravenous and make him
eat more people hurry I don't know about
this hello the gardens done it only took
you fricken forever I'm very pleased
very pleased your king is pleased some
plant people have sprouted in the
gardens are we allowed to make them
official citizens yes are they gonna pay
taxes are they gonna rise up and revolt
like the tree trunks did before I'm
gonna go with yes and then I'm gonna try
not to kill everybody
my brooms all worn out and it's my
birthday oh we did blue or I better not
be expensive on guys expensive ah ah
hello
devise the blueprint for a gold
generating machine it'll take some time
and many resources but it'll produce
gold steadily for the rest of eternity
alright I got the gold alright okay
let's see where this goes okay oh hey
I'm working on a video game is this new
thing I came up with think it'll catch
on yeah yeah alright okay sell it and
give me the money it's game you play
with others to go around killing
monsters you get a sword yeah okay so
it's great right so when you slay a
monster you get experience points and
hey are you still listening
yeah yes I am good well thanks for
listening to my idea thanks for the gold
I suppose
scientists have constructed a large
factory for their work on gold
generation pollution becomes a problem
for nearby homes who cares they're happy
enough as it is they can sacrifice a
little happiness oh hey hello I'm from a
neighboring ocean Kingdom what a lovely
castle you have although it is quite dry
have you ever been to the ocean Kingdom
no no I haven't I see not much of a
swimmer are you I can't fault you for
that Oh
alright bye I want to go alright
I'm gonna leave the kingdom now to
pursue my dream of becoming a game dev
goodbye all right goodbye
it was lovely to have you whoa maybe our
paths will cross again one day probably
not though
take this cog to remember me by oh
that's so sweet he's gone forever
oh nice guy yay we're over a thousand
now we've made a lot of progress we met
some new people but we got a lot more to
do we still have to kill that goddamn
dragon we got to make that gold-making
machine yes
oh geez additional funding hundred gold
alright fine this better be a lot of
gold it generates not just one a day how
to generate a lot o the boundary of your
expanding city is beginning to conflict
with the border of my nation more
specifically your workers have begun
constructing a fence in my backyard
there's made even more affronting by the
fact that my backyard is underwater I
demand that you cease construction of
this fence and maintain your border at
its current position yes good now if
you'll excuse me I've got some cleaning
up and around my property I don't know
what that did or what ramifications that
had oh I'm at Reve the Western ok ahh
Oh Oh No Oh
[Music]
ah ah so much gold I killed so many
people for this gold but they caused me
such a problem okay okay mmm this gold
making machine better work I will speak
be speaking with your Maison immediately
regarding matters of sustainable
woodland harvesting you've done the
right thing here my good Treefolk will
respect that despite your woodcutters
aggression with this I bid you good-day
maybe your roots go dripping strong
alright thank you for not being a little
[ __ ] Oh
ah no okay no not today little Fang it's
been a bad day I got a one I got a kill
this dragon number two my gold making
machines got to be done number three I
need a sandwich yeah a couple Teac
should be very nice what the curse has
been lifted
I'm not hungry for humans anymore this
is great I feel so free maybe I can find
something better to do with all my money
now like charity work or something it's
a whole new Chester well chat no
Cheswick just dirt I like the fact that
you gave me money Yeah right just aruki
just as good okay
just your dad it better be done it
better be done it better be doing
your loom women my mama who did you get
him did you find yarn oh hey uh uh you
got me that cat just wouldn't leave me
alone until I came back here was a
button boy who sent the cat he's been
trying to steal my position as advisor
for years he claims to be the true
advisor but it's just a lie he's only a
button after all I
yarn oh the blue and the true advisor to
the comfy Kingdom accept no substitute
whoops gotta run okay yeah okay guard
see that yarn well done sir I'm not sure
how about how much a part you actually
played in this but yarn has been found
I'm in a generous mood so I'll set up a
meeting with adviser Pia the celestial
kingdom
she's quite bitty but you should expect
her to come by soon make sure this
castle is nicely clean you'll want to
impress her okay
oh no wonderful to see you again kingly
person although I'm a bit sad Albert and
I are gonna be leaving
we'd like to wander and besides we
mustn't overstay our welcome we'll be on
our way tonight but might we have your
blessing before we go yeah but I'll be
sad to see you go who's so lovely to
have met you I wishing you nothing but
happiness oh if only you knew how many
people I killed for money
oh hey my kingdoms done nice oh you
better have it done three I'll have 300
ah I don't have 300 yeah Oh God
someone give me gold someone give me go
right now right now yes okay who faster
we need that money yeah we needed that
money we can do without people [ __ ] yeah
but good god we needed that money
oh I was close I was way too close
sure hey all right we got enough
happiness okay okay climb it back from
the brink you know what let's roll the
dice let's see what happens
oh hell yeah oh yeah okay Lady Luck is
smiling on us once again
oh the dragonblade Oh hurts us some top
quality but we need you you do your
thing because if we can kill that
goddamn dragon then we're gonna get some
goddamn money and Kingdom keep our
goddamn Kingdom in line oh grandma thank
you I'm gonna take that money here I'm
gonna take it
[Music]
oh no you would sure no you're fine come
on you're fine forgive me Oh kind and
gracious lord bless you you're fine dude
I need you to kill the dragon anyway man
that council better have that goddamn
gold-making machine done this cost me
like [ __ ] 1200 gold the Derby Laura
two gold oh hello oh it's adviser Pia
greetings I'm Pia advisor to King and
dramatis of the celestial kingdom
what a beautiful castle you have here
everything is spotless I was just
wandering through your city and was
quite impressed with your citizens
you know the Council of crowns is
searching for a fifth member is that
something you'd be interested in hell
yeah oh yeah oh yeah hell yeah
oh my was that the woman from the
celestial kingdom oh you know it is this
is so exciting the celestial King sits
at the head of the Council of crowns and
in connection with them will surely do
us well in the future I know I know it
I'm aware I know it oh good job man
you're doing great
I just got to kill this dragon yes feel
very spooky oh that's not right I didn't
need to do that oops
dude you Oh God
fine workers you can take you can take
workers that's fine you can take people
that's fine just give me my goddamn gold
dude ah get this gold making machine
done and I won't kill you
I've been asked by a warrior tribe to
the south to supply a great number of
weapons well I have your permission to
supply them I'll need them extra gold to
fill the order yes
[Music]
okay hope they don't attack us with your
weapons make way make way for King and
dramatist Lord of the celestial kingdom
he is here to bless us with his astral
oh my god you're floating you don't
always need to make such a fuss about my
entrances via anyway yes hello Good King
I've heard about you and your people we
in the council are quite impressed with
you and would love to induct you that's
just one small issue I'll for the
existing council members must be present
to induct a new member but I'm afraid
Queen chanterelle and Queen cereth are
having a bit of a fight at the moment
we'll need to calm them down and settle
their dispute before you can join the
council you should be hearing from their
advisers shortly I'm entrusting you with
the task of reconciling the two Queens
best of luck to you and afterwards that
seat on the council
shall be yours okay so this is
interesting I'll keep an eye out for the
advisors from the ocean and plant
kingdom sir I'm sure we can settle
whatever is troubling their Queens so
this is this is interesting okay I've
been playing for nearly an hour here Oh
God you'll put on a show we're already
happy enough shut the [ __ ] up
but this game now has a save mechanic so
on the horizon I need to slay a dragon
finish a gold making machine reconcile
two queens and then join the celestial
kingdom or not the celestial kingdom the
Council of crowns so hopefully I can get
to that but this is just getting a bit
too long for one episode here so I'm
actually gonna finish this up in another
one so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]
member
[Music]